ich fliege dem helikopter a b 212 der
arbeitswelt ist ein
mehrzweckhubschrauber und wie der name
schon sagt wird der vielfältig
eingesetzt
das beginnt beim einfachen
personentransport über truppentransport
einsätze mit spezialeinsatzkräften
winden einsätze außen lasten bis hin zum
see konzert als burg
den typischen dienstag oder alltag gibt
es eigentlich nicht wenn man es darauf
herunter reduzieren kann ist es das
wetter brief in der früh und die danach
folgende auftrags verteilung die kann
allerdings das gesamte einsatz betten
umfassen und ist daher sehr
abwechslungsreich
mein bisheriges highlight war eine
internationale übung in portugal an der
mehrere nationen europas teilgenommen
haben und bei der ich an einem tag für
eine mission als mission commander
verantwortlich war für den einsatz von
über 20 luftfahrzeugen darunter jets
kampfhubschrauber und transporter
pilot beim bundesheer bin ich deshalb
geworden weil ich neben pilot auch
soldat sein wollte und weil der
abwechslungsreichtum einfach viel größer
ist als wäre das alles andere
auslandseinsätzen über das weit
gefächerte einsatzspektrum dass wir
abdecken